Turkey is set to launch its long-planned
offensive against Kurdish fighters in
northern Syria the US has reportedly
started withdrawing troops from the area
clearing the way for the incursion to go
ahead now US troops were stationed close
to the border with Turkey where they
were supporting Kurdish forces in the
fight against the so-called Islamic
state Turkey sees these Kurdish militias
as terrorists on Sunday Kurdish groups
in the region held a mass demonstration
against the Turkish offensive they say
they feel abandoned by the US after
teaming with Kurdish fighters in the
battle against the so-called Islamic
state and let's get the latest on the
story DW Julia Hahn is in Istanbul for
us hi Yulia why is this happening now
well this is basically US President
Donald Trump suddenly making way for
turkeys military operation in northern
Syria this definitely comes as a
surprise and it follows developments
late last night a phone call between
Trump and Turkey's president Reggie ty
appeared on after which the White House
published a statement saying that Turkey
will soon move forward with its long
planned military operation in
northeastern Syria and that US forces
will not support or be involved in it
and what we are seeing on the ground is
that US troops have started in the
morning withdrawing from areas in
northern Syria areas that are so far
controlled by Syrian Kurdish militia and
this is actually you know a major shift
a stunning reversal of US policy in
Syria because Washington had so far
significantly supported the Syrian
Kurdish militia and considered them the
most effective group in the fight
against the so-called Islamic state
while Turkey actually considers them
terrorists and that was the reason for
major disagreement between Washington
and Ankara in the past months and now it
seems Ankara got what it wanted what
will happen now Yulia are we gonna see
Turkish forces move into the area
there are actually many many unanswered
questions right now concerning the scale
and the timeframe of this Turkish
military operation the Turkish military
has reinforced two troops it has pulled
together and pulled over more military
equipment so they say they are basically
ready and they are just awaiting orders
but it also remains to be seen what's
coming next from Washington because it's
safe to assume that President Trump
doesn't have full support on this from
the administration from some very
high-ranking and important people within
the Pentagon it's safe to assume that
this is basically President Trump coming
up with a decision that needs further
talking in Washington so it's going to
be interesting what we'll hear next from
Washington and usually it just quickly
you know the Kurds say they feel like
they're being abandoned tell us more
about their reaction yeah well they have
condemned the USS move they're saying
that and I quote them here it will have
a great negative impact on the fight
against the so-called Islamic state they
are not the only ones very concerned the
UN the UN's humanitarian coordinator in
Syria has also warned all parties of
causing a major displacement of
civilians in the area he said we don't
know what's going to happen next but we
are prepared for the worst so many
concerns here many open questions all
right our correspondent Yulia Hahn
reporting for us from Istanbul thank you